if you're building a computer vision
application rather than training the
waste from scratch from random
initialization you often make much
faster progress if you download weights
that someone else has already trained on
the network architecture and use that as
pre-training and transfer that to a new
task that you might be interested in do
you computer vision research community
has been pretty good at posting lots of
data sense on the internet so if you
hear of things like image net or and as
Coco or as gal all types of data says
these are the names of different data
sets that people have posted online and
that a lot of computer vision
researchers have trained their
algorithms on sometimes this training
takes several weeks and might take many
many GPUs and the fact that someone else
has done this and gone through the
painful high-performance research
process means that you can often
download open source weights that took
someone else many weeks or months to
figure out and use that it's a very good
initialization for your own neural
network and use transfer learning to
sort of transfer knowledge was on these
very large public datasets to your own
problem let's take a deeper look at how
to do this let's start an example let's
say you're building a CAD detector to
recognize your own pet cat so according
to the internet on Tigger is a common
cat name and Mistie is another common
cat's name and let's say your cats are
called
Tigger and Misty and there's also you
know neither so you have a
classification problem with three
classes as this picture Tigger
or is it misty or is it neither and what
you know the case of both of you has
appearing in a picture now you probably
don't have a lot of pictures of Tigger
or misty so your training set will be
small so what can you do I recommend you
go online and download some open source
implementation of a new network and
download not just the code but also the
weight
and there are a lot of networks and
there lot of networks can download that
have been trained on for example the
image net data set which has a thousand
different classes so the network might
have a soft max unit that outputs one of
a thousand possible classes what you can
do is then get rid of the soft max layer
and create your own soft max unit that
outputs tigger
or misty or neither and in terms of the
network i'd encourage you to think of
all of these layers as frozen so you
freeze the parameters in all of these
layers of the network and you would then
just train the parameters associated
with your soft bands layer which is a
soft matte layer with three possible
outputs you know take a misty or neither
and by using someone else's free train
weights you might prefer get pretty good
performance on this even with a small
data set fortunately a lot of deep
learning frameworks support this mode of
operation and in fact depending on the
framework it might have things like
trainable parameter equals zero you
might set that for some of these earlier
layers in order to just say you know
don't train those weights or sometimes
you have a parameter like freeze equals
one and these are different ways and
different deep learning premium
frameworks that let you specify whether
or not to train the weights associated
or a particular layer and so in this
case you will train only the softmax
layers ways but freeze all of the
earlier layers weights one other neat
trick that may help for some
implementations is that because all of
these early layers are frozen there is
some fixed function that doesn't change
because you're not changing it you're
not training it that takes this input
image X and maps it to some set of
activations
than there so one of the treatment that
could speed up training is you just
precompute that layer the features
reactivations
from that layer and just saved them to
disk and what you're doing is it using
this fixed function in this first part
of the neural network to take as input
any input any image X and compute some
feature vector for it and then your
training a shallow softmax model from
this feature vector to make a prediction
and so one step that could help your
computation is you just pre compute that
layers activation for all the examples
in training set and save them to disk
and then just train a soft mass
classifier on top of that all right so
the advantage of safety disks or the pre
compute method to save to disk method is
that you don't need to recompute those
activations every time you take a leap
off or take a pass through your training
set so this is what you do if you have a
pretty small training set for your task
whatever larger training set so one rule
of thumb is if you have a larger label
data set so maybe you just have a ton of
pictures of Tigger misty as was against
pictures of neither of them one thing
you could do is then freeze fewer layers
so maybe your freeze just these layers
and then train these later layers
although if the output layer has
different causes then you need to you
know have your own output unit
anyway take a misty or neither and there
are a couple ways to do this you could
take the last few layers and there a
couple ways to do this you could take
the loss view as weights and just use
that as initialization and do great
descent from there or you can also blow
away these lost few layers and just you
know use your own new hidden units and
in your own final softmax output so
either of these methods could be worth
trying
but maybe one pattern is if you have
more data the number of layers you
freeze could be smaller and then the
number of layers you train on top could
be greater and the idea is that if
you're bigger data set then maybe of
enough data not just to Train a single
softmax unit but to Train some you know
mother size new network that comprises
the last few layers of this final
network the end up using and then
finally if you have a lot of data one
thing you might do is take this open
source network and wait and use the
whole thing just as initialization and
train the whole network although again
if this was a thousand node softmax and
you have just three outputs you need
your own softmax output to output the
labels you care about but the more label
data you have for your tasks so the more
pictures you have of take a misty and
neither the more layers you could train
and in the extreme case you could use
the way to download just as
initialization so they would replace
random initialization and you could do
gradient descent training updating all
the ways in all the layers of the
network so that's transfer learning for
the training of confidence in practice
because the open datasets on the
Internet are so big and the ways you can
download that someone else has spent
weeks training has learned from so much
data you find that for a lot of computer
vision applications you just do much
better if you download someone else's
open source ways and use that as
initialization for your problem so in
all the different disciplines and all
the different applications of deep
learning I think that computer vision is
one where transfer learning is something
that you should almost always do unless
you actually have a very very large
unless you have an exceptionally large
dataset they train everything else from
scratch himself but transfer learning is
just very worth seriously considering on
you have an exceptionally large dataset
and a very large computational budget
they trade everything from scratch by
yourself